le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
faire découvrir et préserver la flore de
l'île
ce sont les objectifs du jardin
botanique mascarin situé à saint leu sur
un ancien domaine de la famille de
chateauvieux le site est passé sous
l'égide du conseil départemental en 2014
et vient de fêter ses 30 ans d'existence
[Musique]
c'est dans les hauteurs de saint-leu que
le domaine mascarin surplombe l'océan un
emplacement qui ne doit rien au hasard
à sa création au xviiie siècle le lieu
avait un rôle stratégique
à l'époque quand c'était la guerre
contre les anglais
vous aviez tout un réseau de vigie vous
aviez une vigie qui était à la saline
une autre vers saint leu est en fait ils
permettaient de surveiller la rade de
saint leu puisque ça le à l'époque était
connu pour la culture du café café qui
était envoyée à la cour du roi en café
qui était précieux donc il fallait
défendre cette rade au début du 19e
siècle la famille de chateauvieux
s'installe sur le site dans une demeure
coloniale
aujourd'hui restauré voilà maintenant
nous trouvons dans la vie la même donc
c'est un lieu vraiment d'accueil pour
nous du public à la fois parce que ça
nous permet de retrouver l'ambiance de
de ces maisons de maître dans les
période 1900 donc avec le des jolies
parquet par exemple on a du grand dague
tina du corps fait blancs dans ses parcs
est le domaine prend alors une fonction
agricole la famille cultive de la can du
géranium ou encore du thé à l'arrière de
la bâtisse les vestiges de cette
activité ont survécu faut plonger dans
l'histoire et imaginer une grande course
simplement où les charrettes de cannes
avait de la place pour manoeuvrer donc
le bassin était construit beaucoup plus
tard nous avions aussi un moulin à
pistache donc pour produire de l'huile
d'arachide un pressoir pour le fibre et
puis un moulin à maïs pour faire la
farine aussi bien pour les gens et pour
les animaux
longtemps géré par une association
le domaine est aujourd'hui la propriété
du département de la réunion ses
extérieurs accueille un jardin botanique
à la fois lieu de conservation de
présentation et de sensibilisation au
patrimoine végétal de lille
quand ce propos c'est de parcourir en
quelques mètres l'équivalent de 800
mètres d'altitude
on va passer différents différents
paysages donc là par exemple on se
retrouve à l'équivalent de la pointe au
sel en bord de mer et on s'aperçoit que
tout de suite au début
eh bien on a plutôt des lianes pourquoi
parce qu'on est sur du sable dans
quelque chose de mou vent il ya les
embruns dont il pense qu'il faut pour
les arbres plus loin sur le sentier les
tiges s'allongent les arbres s'étire
vers le ciel
certaines espèces sont l'incarnation de
la fragilité de l'écosystème local
ici on est avec plantes bien
particulière qu'on appelle le bois
d'ortie on a même deux espèces de
papillons qui vivent sur cet arbre là
est en fait un dead un de ces papillons
ne vit exclusivement que sur le bois
d'ortie sache ni ne mangent que des
feuilles de bois d'ortie voulu donner
d'autres feuilles en voudra pas donc si
l'arbre disparaît le papillon lui aussi
disparaît oui pour nous c'est vraiment
important de dire voilà c'est pas qu'un
pied de bois c'est pas voilà c'est pas
il n'a pas eu un intérêt pour des
propriétés forcément médicinales ou
alimentaires il est important parce
qu'il a sa place dans l'écosystème dans
la dans le réseau de la biodiversité
c'est important pour le département que
chacun puisse s'approprier ce domaine et
connaître un peu plus donc le patrimoine
végétal de la réunion il faut savoir que
sur ce domaine nous avons le jardin
botanique de mascarin et le
conservatoire
alors ensemble donc le département et
les agents qui sont nous voulons ouvrir
cet espace au grand public et surtout
aux enfants de 3 à 15 ans à travers des
ateliers des activités pédagogiques ce
que vous connaissez cette première
plante à tisanes cette année le domaine
propose entre autres un circuit autour
des saveurs en amérique du sud nana ça
veut dire parfum nananana le parfum des
parfums à nana on ne protège que ce
qu'on connaît donc l'idée de essayer de
valoriser en fait des actions de
développement durable passe forcément
par faire connaître justement ce
patrimoine végétal
c'est vrai qu'on dispose là de tout un
tas d'espèces qui sont extrêmement
ludique on l'a vu ensemble avec des
parfums avec des saveurs avec un touché
voilà on essaie d'avoir une approche
très sensorielle de ces espèces
pour les faire découvrir les faire
connaître et mieux les respecter par la
suite le piment cabri extrêmement fort
donc renseignez vous avant de manger un
cari suis là comme on dit aux toges bien
il est extrêmement fort donc voilà afin
de toucher un public plus large
le jardin continue d'étendre ses racines
le département réfléchit déjà aux
prochains aménagements jardin c'est
toujours en devenir
donc effectivement pour nous aujourd'hui
il ya toujours un souci de créer de
nouvelles choses d'améliorer donc on a
d'une part un rush et pédagogique qu'on
aimerait pouvoir compléter d'une école
d'apiculture parce que justement il ya
ce lien on plantes insectes qui est
essentielle pour l'agriculture de demain
on parle beaucoup des plantes
médicinales donc là aussi il serait
importante pour nous que les gens
puissent trouver un lieu pour pouvoir
découvrir les espèces médicinales et
notamment celle de la pharmacopée
réunionnaise tout au long de l'année on
essaye de conduire différents
rendez-vous pour familiariser les gens
pour les inviter à venir pour 6 et du
plaisir à visiter le jardin c'est
vraiment ce qui nous réjouit
[Musique]
le jardin botanique mascarin est réparti
sur plus de trois hectares
il comporte huit collections végétales
vivante illustre la biodiversité de
l'île
il propose également des actions
diversifiées de sensibilisation et des
ateliers découverte les dépendances du
domaine accueille régulièrement des
expositions
le jardin botanique est ouvert du mardi
au dimanche de 9h à 17h en visite libre
ou guidée
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cnrs.fr
[Musique]